[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros comenzamos
madagascar la isla más grande de áfrica
vive una hambruna que afecta a un millón
y medio de personas un desastre del que
poco se conoce en el mundo esta grave
crisis alimentaria necesita asistencia
de emergencia pero mientras llega sigue
muriendo decenas de personas debido al
ante la onu dice que el sur de la isla
está sufriendo la peor sequía desde hace
cuatro décadas lo que arrasó con casi
todos los cultivos sin embargo el
gobierno se niega a declarar esa
emergencia se encuentra con nosotros
calvos ya ella es una de las autoras del
reportaje que veremos en minutos galp
gracias por estar con nosotros las
personas están muriendo de hambre qué
condiciones se encontró usted durante la
realización de este reportaje
[Música]
en efecto las condiciones fueron
difíciles en primera medida porque es un
área remota a la cual es muy difícil
acceder por ejemplo no podíamos conducir
de noche debido a la inseguridad el
programa mundial de alimentos y las
autoridades locales nos pidieron ser muy
cuidadosos muchas personas nos
advirtieron que no fuéramos porque
oficialmente es una zona roja en donde
hay ataques armados constantemente
gracias a vos ya aquí el reportaje de la
hambruna que se vive en madagascar
y
[Música]
pocos son los que se aventuran por este
camino porque aquí prevalece lo dahal
bandidos armados que aterrorizan y
saquean los pueblos
nos adentramos en las tierras del
extremo sur de madagascar en nuestro
camino
esta aldea parece un pueblo fantasma no
hay rastro de ganado robado hace mucho
tiempo por los bajas
esta mujer de pueblo de 50 años nos
invita a su casa donde vive con su
cuñada bueno ahora no se calmarán mal
alimentada su hija de dos años no camina
para tranquilizarla solo tiene una
solución no tienes que tomar mucho con
el resto allí
se está calmando porque está comiéndose
los grillos allí llora porque tiene
hambre
el sur de madagascar se ha visto
afectado por una grave sequía que ha
destruido casi todos los cultivos
hace casi dos años que no tenemos
cosecha solo buscamos tubérculos desde
que llovió las larvas de grillos han
estado incubando
afortunadamente eso nos salvó
si no hubiera grillos estaríamos todos
muertos
la ayuda alimentaria que recibieron hace
un mes se agotó así que es la misma
comida todos los días a la espera de la
siguiente distribución con agua o se
quemara no debe quedar demasiado salado
en madagascar un millón y medio de
personas sufren la peor crisis
alimentaria de la última década la causa
es una sequía crónica que ha durado más
de un siglo incluso tiene un nombre en
el dialecto del sur le quiere
el pasado mes de octubre las fotos de
niños esqueléticos publicadas en las
redes habían molestado a los internautas
el presidente vino en persona pero desde
entonces debido a la falta de recursos
la situación ha empeorado sin
estadísticas oficiales las muertes
continúan a pesar de la intervención de
muchas ong y del estado para estas
poblaciones abandonadas a su suerte los
días transcurren salpicados por el
hambre y el miedo a los ataques de
rodajas
los dahal vinieron a llevarse nuestros
bueyes vinieron del norte silbaba en
piri piri piri disparaban nosotros
corríamos hacia el bosque
los ataques se repetían y se llevaban
los bueyes luego volvían y se llevaban
las cabras y las ollas después de
cocinar los grillos volvemos al bosque
porque tenemos miedo
[Música]
alertado el pm programa mundial de
alimentos interviene
distribución inmediata de raciones de
alimentos
los grillos han dado paso a plantados
una harina fortificada diseñada para
prevenir la desnutrición infantil
el amarillo es desnutrición aguda
moderada pero el rojo es realmente grave
así que tenemos que trasladar a esta
niña al hospital el mayor reto para el
pm y gestionar la emergencia nutricional
además de la inseguridad la distribución
de alimentos está centralizada en una
comuna a 20 kilómetros de aquí y la zona
está plagada de dahal individuos
bloquean el camino de los residentes
cuando llevan las donaciones de
alimentos desde allí los bajas les roban
y vuelven con las manos vacías no pueden
llevar la comida a casa así que
prefieren comer el software y en lugar
de traerlo aquí la nicotina donde a ti
si no los roban el dia que vuelven o si
no los han visto están robando
directamente en las casas
así que esos son los grillos que se
comen
[Música]
hay sequía hay inseguridad así que al
final nos enfrentamos a dos situaciones
muy complicadas los bandidos han ido
arrancar yo acá que todavía no está
buena para comer
la sacan de los cultivos ya no sé qué
pasará con la gente y la mayoría de las
personas de este pueblo les ocuparon el
pueblo por la inseguridad de acordar la
sécurité se ofrece una comida caliente
para los más débiles
una gacha dulce elaborada con harina de
maíz y legumbre mezclada con agua baldes
de plástico reemplazan las joyas robadas
necesitan comer rápido antes de que los
bajas vengan a robar lo poco que se gana
hoy puede ser robado mañana anuncio puro
vicioso que mantiene a la gente en la
pobreza
en cuanto se sirven las gachas el pm a
interviene en una aldea vecina donde hay
tres niños en estado crítico se
trasladan inmediatamente a este pequeño
centro de salud básico
esta niña de 2 años tiene que ser
trasladada urgentemente al centro de
nutrición del hospital su pronóstico es
reservado pero el centro está a más de 2
horas de distancia y solo hay una
ambulancia
es posible enviar la ambulancia para
recoger a tres niños que están en un
estado muy crítico ahora mismo el ciclo
[Música]
porque solo vienes aquí ahora
como habían dahal en mi casa teníamos
miedo y corrimos al bosque uno de mis
hijos murió
lo enterramos el viernes pasado y tengo
este conmigo
qué está pasando va a morir si no llega
la ambulancia
creo que la ambulancia vendrá porque la
enviarán si todavía pueden soportar el
mejor soporte de wilde
como humanitario experimentado theodor
nunca se ha enfrentado a tanta marsella
si no los enviamos ahora va a ser muy
grave así que contamos con ustedes
gracias
ante una situación así todos nos vemos
afectados yo tengo hijos así que mis
hijos también podrían correr la misma
suerte
debido a los ataques dos centros de
salud del distrito han cerrado el estado
solo dedica el 7 por ciento de su
presupuesto a la sanidad muy lejos del
15% recomendado por la unión africana la
ambulancia llegará a tiempo se logrará
salvar la vida de esa pasó a
frente a este bandolerismo rural algunas
distribuciones de alimentos se realizan
bajo escolta militar en este pueblo 25
gendarmes se han instalado en dos aulas
convertidas en dormitorios
ahora hay un poco de desorden no tuvimos
tiempo de ordenar
la usada la unidad especial entidad
creada en 2016 es el único grupo de
élite para un distrito de 340 mil
habitantes
de ahí la necesidad de formar comités de
autodefensa en las aldeas para dar la
alarma en caso de ataque
cuando cae la noche tenemos que seguir
trabajando como lo hacemos durante el
día
cuando vuelven del mercado no pueden
aprovechar para beber alcohol también
hay que avisar a los que vuelven del
campo ya todos los jóvenes para que
organicen la vigilancia del barrio está
claro
desde la llegada de la usach se acabaron
las noches en el bosque para esconderse
de lodazal
antes de que llegara la usap todos
habían abandonado el pueblo todo el
mundo tenía miedo
robaban casas coches motos aquí podemos
vivir normalmente cultivar nuestros
campos tranquilos una calma precaria
paul sabe que una vez que la usal se
vaya los habitantes del pueblo volverán
a estar a merced de los bajado
además de la usal los 225 gendarme de
distrito de otras unidades no impidieron
los ataques ni mucho menos
en el hospital de amboage área y la
capital del distrito esta pareja y su
hijo de nueve meses acaban de ser
apuñalados en su casa no tenían dinero
para entregar un amigo policía vino a
visitarlos víctima de una agresión
también en su casa no duda en denunciar
un sistema que protege a los bajas
hay gente que interviene por políticos
al acecho que quieren liberarlos de la
cárcel ahora mismo
las acusaciones de complicidad se
multiplica
a veces los bajas logran cambiar a una
carrera administrativa
[Música]
se trata de una situación insostenible
que está provocando la huida de miles de
personas a regiones más apacibles el
número de migrantes climáticos se ha
disparado en pocos meses
en este centro dirigido por monjas 3.000
personas reciben un poco de comida cada
día tierras que se han vuelto infértiles
casas utensilios lo han perdido todo
entre ellos está agua de 45 años tras
una semana caminando llego aquí por
consejo de otros migrantes los que
estaban delante de mí ya están allí y no
puedo colarme con un niño
el centro no tiene ni espacio ni medios
para acoger a los migrantes ovas se ha
instalado en este campo fue capaz de
construir este refugio con lo que
encontró en el suelo
tuvimos que pedir prestados los
cubiertos dos cucharas para ella y sus
ocho hijos de una cuchara por favor en
su turno ya está déjame comer ahora oh
por dios
creen que son los únicos que tienen que
sobrevivir
vendimos nuestro terreno por sólo 20
euros aunque era enorme
después de gastarlo todo nos fuimos no
nos quedaba comida así es como hemos
llegado hasta aquí afortunadamente
alguien nos ayudó de lo contrario mis
hijos habrían muerto en el camino
la hija de 12 años de jehova no ha
renunciado a sus sueños
mi sueño es tener un trabajo para poder
ayudar a mi madre ya mi padre mensaje al
presidente que nos construyó una casa
que nos compre ollas platos y cucharas y
que nos construya una casa
y me gustaría ir a la escuela
a la espera de volver algún día a jehová
solo le quedan la canción y los
recuerdos de su tierra la tierra de las
espinas
[Música]
sí no
en su región android las tormentas de
arena se suceden y sepultan los campos
las escasas subidas ya no permiten el
cultivo ante la aceleración del cambio
climático global la delincuencia
incontrolada y la debilidad del estado
las esperanzas de volver de caoba se
convierten poco a poco en un espejismo
regresamos con una de las autoras del
reportaje sobre la hambruna en
madagascar gal y le pregunto ahora desde
que usted realizó este reportaje ha
visto alguna señal de mejora en las
personas que conocían
sí
la situación no ha mejorado para nada
diría que se ha puesto peor se que en
algunas poblaciones la ayuda alimentaria
aún no ha llegado tenemos el ejemplo de
una comunidad en la región android al
sur de madagascar donde 30 personas
principalmente niños han muerto porque
la ayuda alimentaria llegó demasiado
tarde debemos saber que esta crisis
alimentaria en fue anticipada por lo que
ahora las autoridades enfrentan una
emergencia que es muy costosa porque
deben llevar toneladas de alimentos a
áreas remotas para ayudar a miles de
personas y misiones
el programa mundial de alimentos tiene
dificultad de recogiendo los 76 millones
de dólares para enfrentar esta crisis y
también el gobierno malgache no ha
puesto mucho dinero sobre la mesa para
ayudar a esta región a 16
monjack de chubut
hay que tener en cuenta que estas
personas deben ser ayudadas en los meses
venideros porque no pueden cultivar no
tienen otras fuentes de ingresos y si no
se les ayuda a correr un riesgo enorme
de perecer pero no
en el reportaje usted habla sobre cómo
el fenómeno da a la grava la crisis un
policía habla de los delincuentes que se
benefician de esto y de los políticos
que cobran que es este fenómeno tal
y la principal actividad de los bandidos
es el robo de ganado y cuando eres parte
de este negocio ilegal
debes lavar el ganado
y administration su hija debes hacer
papeles falsos para poderlo vender por
lo que necesitas cómplices dentro de la
administración entonces tenemos lo que
llamamos en madagascar dal de cuello
blanco y estos son personas en el poder
servidores públicos quienes pueden
corromper la administración y pagar la
salida de prisión de los datos
y algunos oficiales de la fuerza pública
por ejemplo venden sus armas y sus
municiones a los dados entonces esta es
una enorme y bien organizada red
criminal por lo que una gran parte de la
fuerza pública que no hace parte de este
sistema son víctimas y se toman la
justicia por mano propia
esto nos dijo el oficial de policía en
esta entrevista
si nosotros la policía le disparamos
saludar sus derechos estarán
garantizados pero si nos disparan no
tenemos derechos eso es sorprendente los
derechos humanos no se respetan en ambas
hay lo que funciona en ambas hay es
matarlos cuando los atrapamos
gracias a albor ya por traernos este
reportaje sobre la hambruna por la que
está pasando madagascar los entonces
también gracias por acompañarnos
recuerde que puede ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta la próxima
semana
[Música]